Traduttore: Jessica Venarotta
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Immagina:
sei nella tua casa
e arriva un'onda alta tre metri,
spinta da un vento
a 300 km all'ora.
Quest'onda travolge tutto.
Questo è quello che è successo
nelle Filippine, ad Haiti.
Quest'onda travolge tutto
e tutti i tuoi ricordi, le tue foto,
la tua casa, i tuoi averi, i tuoi beni,
e forse anche i tuoi cari,
vengono spazzati via.
Immagina,
stai andando a 300 all'ora,
il mondo è ai tuoi piedi.
Stai vincendo tutto.
Ti senti padrone di te stesso
e di tutto quello che succede.
Hai tutto sotto controllo.
E improvvisamente succede
qualche cosa che non avevi previsto,
e ti trovi in un letto
in cui non hai controllo di nulla.
Immagina,
la tua mamma non ti riconosce più.
Non sa più chi sei
e quando ti vede ti chiama:
"Signorina lei è graziosa,
mi ricorda una persona che conoscevo".
Immagina di essere tu,
quella persona che non riconosce più
le persone e i visi che sono attorno a te.
Qualche volta la malattia fa questo:
ci mette in un tunnel,
in cui non sempre siamo in grado
di vedere la luce.
Il grande poeta Rilke diceva:
"Soltanto quando la sofferenza
psichica ci colpisce
possiamo cogliere in noi
delle risorse potenzialmente creatrici.
Non c'è conoscenza,
né esperienza creativa,
senza sofferenza.
Il nostro corpo e la nostra mente,
non sono separati.
Noi siamo il nostro corpo."
Come dice un grande psichiatra
italiano, Eugenio Borgna:
"Ogni malattia, specie se protratta,
ha una risonanza nella vita psichica
perché entriamo in contatto
con la nostra fragilità.
È una conoscenza che ci aiuta
a comprendere meglio
le nostre attitudini interiori.
Noi scopriamo sentimenti, emozioni,
forza, debolezza, problemi
che altrimenti non avremmo
mai potuto cogliere,
non avremmo mai conosciuto".
Il modello medico, come la medicina
negli ultimi 100 anni,
ci ha insegnato che può essere -
la medicina vede il corpo malato
come una macchina guasta:
qualche cosa in cui io posso riparare,
e la macchina può ripartire.
Il modello biomedico,
negli ultimi 100 anni,
ci ha portato risultati strepitosi:
gli antibiotici hanno
sconfitto le malattie,
il modello biomedico funziona benissimo!
la chirurgia, l'anestesia, i progressi
hanno sicuramente portato
a un grandissimo vantaggio
per l'uomo, per l'umanità.
Però questo modello biomedico,
questo modello dell'uomo-macchina,
in un certo senso
sta mostrando qualche limite.
La popolazione mondiale invecchia.
Per me, come medico,
è uno dei successi
più strepitosi della medicina.
Per molti, per i politici,
per coloro che devono
organizzare la salute,
è vista come una cosa terrorizzante.
Ma assieme all'invecchiamento,
io ho anche un aumento
delle malattie croniche,
un aumento dell'ipertensione, del diabete,
delle malattie cardiologiche,
dell'obesità, di malattie che restano:
soprattutto le malattie del cervello,
le malattie neurologiche,
le malattie psichiatriche aumentano.
E sono malattie per le quali,
in qualche modo, il panorama cambia.
Non basta più
il modello biomedico, perché -
dove sta la patologia?
In gran parte di queste malattie
io non so che cosa togliere,
non so qual è il guasto
che io posso riparare
per far ripartire questa macchina-corpo,
questa macchina-uomo
perfettamente sana, perfettamente integra.
Che cosa togliere? Che cosa aggiungere?
È molto difficile.
Curare, oggi, spesso significa
regolare un sistema
di cui non sappiamo veramente
bene dove è il guasto.
È necessario quindi forse
ripensare alla medicina.
Pensare a una medicina
che torni al klinèin:
in greco klinèin vuol dire chinarsi,
ed è lì che nasce la medicina clinica.
Chinarsi, è quello che fa il medico
quando si china verso il paziente.
Allora è forse tempo di pensare
che la medicina è sì spazio,
la prestazione, l'efficienza, la tecnologia -
abbiamo visto prima, la tecnologia
può fare delle cose straordinarie -
ma la medicina è anche tempo:
il tempo della malattia.
E dal primato della prestazione,
quello che lo spazio ci fa fare,
la fantastica progressione dell'umano,
che è quello che noi vediamo
con i grandi progressi della medicina,
forse dovremmo pensare
che potrebbe essere rivalutata,
allora, un'altra parte:
la parte del tempo.
Il tempo inteso come il tempo
della malattia nel quale io ho relazione.
Il tempo della malattia,
che non è un tempo perso.
Come diceva Nietzsche:
"Ci si guardi dall'essere
malati troppo a lungo:
giacché tosto gli spettatori
s'impazientiscono
a causa dell'obbligo abituale
di mostrare compassione,
dato che il mantenere a lungo
in se stessi questo stato
costa loro troppa fatica -
e allora passano, immediatamente,
a rendere sospetto il vostro carattere,
con la conclusione
che voi meritate di essere malati,
e non è più necessario
che noi ci si affatichi
con la compassione.
Tanti anni fa viveva Nietzsche, ma
in realtà questa impazienza contemporanea
è quella che facilita assolutamente
l'entrata all'interno del nostro pensare,
del nostro quotidiano,
della nostra contemporanea impazienza.
Quella che viene chiamata
"la cultura dello scarto".
Quella che privilegia l'uomo maschio,
quarantenne, produttore -
bello, possibilmente,
a quella che è la realtà di ognuno di voi,
a quella che è la nostra realtà.
Una cultura dello scarto
c'è già stata e c'è sempre,
ma quello che noi dobbiamo
in qualche modo ricordarci
è che non è che è passata.
L'uomo perfetto come modello porta
ad avere una cultura dello scarto.
Qui, ora, oggi,
qui a Bergamo, qui in Italia,
qui in Europa, qui nel mondo,
la cultura dello scarto per cui,
se non sei perfetto, tu sei scarto.
Le persone non sono la malattia che hanno.
Oggi si festeggia, nel mondo,
un certo tipo di persone
che sono abituate
a lavorare sulla disabilità.
[Sono] 16 anni da quando l'OMS ha detto:
"La disabilità non è soltanto
la malattia che hai,
ma è la malattia che hai
nell'ambiente in cui sei.
E questo ambiente
può essere una barriera.
E questo modello,
che in qualche modo fa suo
il modello biomedico,
si chiama "modello biopsicosociale":
un modello all'interno del quale
l'interazione uomo-ambiente è cruciale.
Perché spesso noi, quando abbiamo
delle malattie croniche,
tendiamo a considerare
che questa mano, questa artrite,
questa mano che rende difficile
fare delle cose,
sia l'essenza di una persona.
In realtà nonna Maria
vuole essere una nonna.
Una nonna che è utile ancora
alla sua famiglia, a sua nipote.
Una nonna che, malgrado la sua malattia,
rimane la persona che è.
E allora, affermare che qualcuno
è degno di rispetto,
e che detiene dei diritti
non perché disabile,
ma perché persona, malgrado la malattia,
significa anche chiarire
che non c'è niente di buono
nella disabilità.
Noi ricercatori
la malattia la combattiamo,
cerchiamo qualche cosa
che vada contro la malattia.
Mai contro il malato.
E allora è l'uomo concreto, reale
malgrado la malattia e la disabilità,
che è degno di rispetto.
In un certo senso
la teoria del "malgrado",
che è una teoria che è stata definita
dal professor Pessina,
un filosofo italiano, nel 2010,
ci dice che:
"Malgrado il fatto
che nessuno qui è perfetto:
in qualche modo, abbiamo tutti
conosciuto la malattia.
Per noi, i nostri cari, i nostri amici.
Ma questo non ha nulla,
della nostra qualità di essere uomo.
Il fatto di essere con una malattia,
con qualcosa che ci rende fragili,
non è che ci renda meno.
Quindi noi siamo uomini degni di dignità
malgrado la malattia.
E allora, se è vero questo modello
bio-psico-sociale
per cui, cambiando forse l'ambiente,
io diminuisco la disabilità,
guardando a quest'interazione,
io forse non posso cambiare la malattia -
perché purtroppo, molte malattie
posso curarle ma non guarirle.
Come neurologo lo dico perché,
dirigendo il centro coma, io questo vedo:
che molte malattie
è molto difficile curarle;
però posso lavorare sull'altra componente
che determina la disabilità, l'ambiente.
L'ambiente che può essere
facilitatore o barriera.
Nell'ambito del nostro
ragionamento collettivo,
molto spesso l'ambiente
è inteso come l'ambiente architettonico
ed è chiaro per molti
che le barriere architettoniche
sono un'ambiente
che può essere modificato.
E se modificato, chiaramente, diminuisce
una disabilità generale, collettiva,
perché è più accessibile o fruibile
tutto quello che è attorno a noi.
Ma in realtà l'ambiente che mi interessa
di più condividere con voi oggi,
è l'ambiente sociale,
l'ambiente delle relazioni:
I vostri amici, i vostri cari,
le persone con cui siete accanto.
L'ambiente sociale che -
in qualche modo, ormai,
gli studi stanno dimostrando,
in maniera inequivocabile,
che avere amici, essere in relazione,
avere delle conoscenze, avere delle reti,
cambia la tua salute.
Se hai degli amici, stai meglio;
ma non stai meglio soltanto in termini
di benessere: stai proprio meglio!
Ci sono degli studi australiani
meravigliosi in cui si dimostrano
che abbiamo una variazione,
nell'ambito del DNA,
se siamo in relazione,
se siamo connessi con delle persone.
In un grande studio europeo,
che abbiamo coordinato
noi del Besta di Milano,
in cui lavoro con i miei ricercatori,
abbiamo visto che avere reti sociali
ha un effetto sulla salute.
Se sei anziano, se sei isolato,
tu stai peggio, ma non perché sei isolato.
È proprio il tuo corpo, che sta male.
Sei proprio tu, che stai male.
In tutti i paesi che abbiamo studiato,
in più di 10.000 persone
che abbiamo intervistato,
la famiglia era sempre
il facilitatore sostanziale.
Mi piace chiamare tutti quei caregiver,
che ho incontrato nei miei 30 anni
di lavoro come neurologa,
i "rivoluzionari della tenerezza".
Un relatore di TED molto famoso,
che ha usato questa espressione
due settimane fa,
"rivoluzionari della tenerezza"
dicendo una cosa:
"Un papà e una mamma,
quando parlano al loro bambino
usando la voce da piccoli:
non sono meno perché usano
questa voce da piccoli,
sono teneri, usano la tenerezza".
Lui, poi, giustamente ha detto:
"Quando Dio è sceso,
e ha parlato tramite un uomo,
non si è fatto di meno
perché usava la tenerezza".
E a me è piaciuto,
quando ho sentito questa cosa,
perché ho pensato: io conosco
un sacco di rivoluzionari.
Quelle madri che per cinque, dieci,
20 anni, stanno vicino al loro figlio
che a 18 anni è uscito di casa la sera,
salutandole, ed è rimasto in coma.
Quelle mogli che restano
vicino ai propri cari.
Mi è piaciuto prima -
scusatemi, lo devo dire -
tutti quei rivoluzionari tecnologici,
erano quasi tutti maschi.
Beh, io invece conosco un sacco
di rivoluzionari femmine.
perché le rivoluzionarie della tenerezza
sono prevalentemente delle donne.
(Applausi)
Sono delle donne che veramente
non hanno un grammo di meno,
perché si sono abbassate
a stare 20 anni senza uscire mai,
perché non avevano nessun aiuto
attorno a loro, alla loro casa.
Son state rivoluzionarie della tenerezza
perché sono state lì,
e non sono andate via.
Io li conosco questi rivoluzionari
della tenerezza,
chissà quanti ce ne sono in sala qua.
E allora la dignità umana
appartiene integralmente all'uomo
malgrado sia malato,
malgrado sia inconsapevole
delle proprie capacità,
malgrado sia fragile,
malgrado gli manchino delle cose.
La dignità e i diritti
sono fondamentalmente, soltanto,
nella sua pura qualità di essere uomo.
E allora anche quando siamo investiti
da uno tsunami, da una malattia,
il tempo della malattia
è il tempo della vita.
Non è un tempo altro.
Per moltissime persone
che vivono tanto tempo con la malattia,
il tempo della malattia è la vita.
E allora il malgrado cosa ci dice?
Ci ricorda
che ciò da cui noi dobbiamo partire,
per progettare questo tempo,
sono delle relazioni significative.
Il malgrado allora ci insegna
che è tempo di essere un Giuseppe.
Cinque anni fa, fui chiamata dall'OMS
per andare nelle Filippine.
Subito dopo lo tsunami,
mi chiesero di andare a fare
una valutazione della disabilità
nella popolazione,
che era stata completamente
devastata da uno tsunami
conosciuto come lo tsunami che seguiva
il più forte tifone della storia:
un vento a 300 km all'ora
che ha spazzato via tutto.
Mi venne a prendere il collega
in questo areoporto mezzo distrutto,
salgo sulla macchina con lui
e cominciamo ad andare
in mezzo allo scenario di Tacloban,
questa città delle Filippine.
E questo era ciò
che si presentava ai miei occhi:
questo era il capannone
dove il Comune aveva detto:
"Andate tutti nel capannone,
che vi salvate".
Questo è quello che è rimasto.
Questa è la nave
che è stata spostata di un km
perché il vento era così forte,
lo tsunami e l'onda così alta
che ha messo questa nave
a un km dalla riva.
Queste erano le persone
che cercavano da mangiare
perché era tutto distrutto,
non c'era più niente, c'erano gli aiuti.
E poi, improvvisamente, arriva Giuseppe.
Tutto distrutto attorno, e io vedo:
"Giuseppe, Ristorante Italiano-Filippino"
E dico a un mio collega: "Ma che cos'è?"
Dice: "Stasera ci andiamo a cena."
"Ah", dico, "va bene!"
Andiamo a cena da Giuseppe la sera,
entro, vedo Giuseppe e dico:
- Giuseppe, [buonasera], piacere.
Da dove viene? - Da Napoli.
- Piacere, e cosa fa? Come mai è qui?
.Non è successo niente, [con] lo tsunami?
- No, io avevo tutto distrutto.
Non c'era più niente.
E allora ho pensato -
ho chiamato tutti i miei camerieri,
ho chiamato il pizzaiolo,
ho chiamato tutti e ho detto:
Non c'è più niente, andate a casa.
Seppellite i vostri morti,
mettete al sicuro le vostre famiglie;
e poi venite qua.
Qui, tra cinque giorni,
arrivano gli aiuti.
Gli aiuti devono mangiare.
Se noi ricostruiamo tutti insieme
questa pizzeria,
noi ce la facciamo a ritirarci su.
Faremo i soldi,
voi ricostruite le vostre case;
però state con me, state insieme.
Giuseppe mi ha insegnato allora una cosa
che tanti dicono, e che è proprio vera:
che anche quando sei nel buio più totale,
una sola candela fa luce.
E che spesso, e io ci credo profondamente,
nelle situazioni anche
un uomo solo fa la differenza.
Ognuno spera sempre
di essere quell'uomo lì;
ma anche se uno
non si sente all'altezza,
se uno si sente inadeguato,
c'è sempre la speranza
che ci sia attorno qualcuno
che possa essere quella candela.
Perché in qualche modo,
quando si è in uno tsunami,
qualunque sia lo tsunami che vivete,
che avete vissuto, che state vivendo,
che vivono i vostri amici,
io credoche sia fondamentale
essere facilitatori gli uni per gli altri.
Credo che sia fondamentale
saper chiedere aiuto,
e anche fondamentale saperlo ricevere.
Credo che sia fondamentale avere coraggio,
e non perdere la speranza
perché qualche candela attorno c'è.
Allora bisogna darsi un obiettivo assieme,
assieme a chi vi vuole bene
e assieme a chi amate.
Insomma: per me,
è tempo di essere un Giuseppe!
(Applausi)